[Musique]
de quoi est ce qu'on parle aujourd'hui
vous le savez vous avez vu le titre de
la vidéo je sais pas pourquoi je fais le
suspense on parle de lui en ce test
c'est le samsung galaxy à 50 il est
sorti ya pas très longtemps je vous
avais déjà emmené avec moi pour le
découvrir ça fait quelques jours que je
lai que j'utilise
il ya des trucs vraiment intéressant
avec ce smartphone il ya d'autres trucs
je suis un peu plus dubitatif on en
parle tout de suite et dans quelques
jours je vous parle celle là là mais
j'ai pris depuis quelques jours c'est la
galaxie active watch
il déballe un monde connecté de samsung
est vachement intéressante alors la
première chose pré requis pour faire
cette vidéo c'est ça
[Musique]
3 4 9 349
c'est le trait du smartphone c'est le
prix du smartphone auquel vous pourrez y
trouver tout de suite
alors je pense que d'ici quelques temps
il va baisser mais c'est une notion très
important pour pouvoir le re situer par
rapport au marché par rapport à son prix
réel par rapport à la concurrence
il ya des choses qui sont bien sûr ce
smartphone il ya des choses que j'aime
moins bien on va toujours re situer par
rapport à son prix parce que c'est un
élément essentiel
les smartphones évoluant on a des gains
technologique au niveau de la photo au
niveau de la rapidité au niveau de pas
mal de choses un dégât technologie qui
arrivé l'année dernière c'est le capteur
d'empreintes digitales
sous l'écran répond depuis un petit
moment et il a fini par arriver alors ça
c'est plutôt bien son principe il ya le
capteur d'écran optique celui qui fait
de la lumière qui doit vous éclairer le
bout du doigt et qui vous permet de lier
dérouiller grâce à votre empreinte vous
en douterez bien évidemment et vous avez
le capteur d'empreinte ultrasonique
comme on en trouve notamment son galaxy
s 10 s10 plus vous posez votre doigt il
des verrous il a plu et il n'avait pas
lu lierse et par un système d'ultrasons
celui là il a le capteur d'empreintes
digitales optique situés ici sous
l'écran et il est bien il ya un gain
technologique mais pour moi il n'ya pas
un gain pour l'utilisateur
quand on a fait un smartphone qu'est ce
qu'on veut on veut en prendre qui
correspondent à nos attentes bien
évidemment mais à notre mode de vie
moi ce que j'aime bien c'est quand je
vois une notification je veux que ça
évite tu pourras le des dérouillées
rapidement pour tout de suite voir ce
que j'ai et là des fois je trouve que
c'est un petit peu long voyez j'ai posé
mon doigt
est-ce qu'il l'a reconnu aucune
correspondance c'est pas tout le temps
il est un peu capricieux quand il veut
il veut bien c'est sympa voiliers et
quand il veut pas il vous embête le
problème c'est que quand il veut aussi
bien mais il est un petit peu lent un
petit peu trop long on va refaire
exercice 1 2 3 voilà au bout de trois
secondes il marque aucune correspondance
on recommence un deux trois ans voilà on
est quasiment à trois secondes pour
l'ouverture sur un capteur d'empreintes
digitales pour moi c'est pas intéressant
parce qu'effectivement on a un gain en
technologie la technologie est là elle
est intéressante elle assez récente
brouille elle fait la petite lumière
mais en termes de gains utilisateurs on
n'y est pas je préférais à ce moment là
qu'on reste sur un capteur à l'arrière
même si effectivement on y perdrait en
termes de design ce design là est
vachement sympa on n'a pas de capteur à
l'arrière par contre on y perd on y
gagne au côté technologique
on y gagne un côté graphique par contre
on y perd en côté pratique et avant
toute chose je crois en nos smartphones
et qui soit pratique est là pour le coup
c'est pas réussi alors je sais je sais
je suis un peu dur je commence avec le
point qui fâche mais c'est vrai que
c'est tout qui est frustrant parce que
votre smartphone est tout le temps dans
votre poche rangé dans un sac quelque
part et tiens j'ai reçu un message ça
vibre à j'appuie je veux voir vous
attendez trois secondes
ça marche ça marche pas alors ça marche
plus souvent que ça marche pas pour ma
part j'ai enregistré deux fois
l'empreinte de mon pouce pour être sûr
que sous différents angles il accepte et
au bout d'un moment
voilà ça me fait un peu râler 349 euros
faut pas l'oublier
j'aurais préféré là dessus que samsung
reste sur une technologie était un petit
peu plus tôt school ou alors carrément
qui nous met un capteur sur la tranche
comme on assure le galaxy s 10e
parce que c'est rapide c'est pratique
vous avez pas forcément gars
technologique parce qu'on n'est pas sûr
dernières technologies mais par contre
en terme d' usage c'est bien vous avez
le game design ça c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment aussi intéressant et
surtout c'est très pratique ça pour moi
c'est un peu le point négatif de ce
smartphone maintenant il ya plein de
belles qualités je voulais mon parce que
c'est un smartphone qui est intéressante
et une fois de plus n'oublions pas 349
euros maintenant les normes point
positif de ce smartphone c'est son écran
il élimine les couleurs sont belles il
est pratique il est sympa c'est vraiment
un très beau travail fait de la part de
samsung a lancé un écran infiniti ue
parce que vous avez ce petit eu là haut
niveau de l'encoche on a un écran de 6,4
pouces full hd + très belles couleurs
très beaux contrastes lumineux samsung
sur maîtrise et écran amoled et c'est
vraiment cool
au-delà de ça vous pouvez aller dans les
paramètres grâce à owen wright selway ce
qui est vraiment vraiment vraiment bien
et vous pouvez faire pas mal de choses
déjà la première chose c'est le mode de
l'écran vous l'aurez par défaut en
cinéma adaptatif
vous pouvez régler la main entre le
chaud et le froid mais moi je trouve
qu'on a des contrastes qui sont pas très
correct vous n'êtes pas forcément vous
en rendre compte tout parce que la vidéo
et colorisé donc on ne va pas forcément
vous mettez sur un cinéma amoled les
couleurs sont beaucoup plus douce
beaucoup plus réelle si vous passez en
photo am oled c'est beaucoup plus saturé
on est un peu plus loin de la réalité
basic fonctionne aussi pour moi le
cinéma molette c'est le mall sur lequel
joe mais je trouverais mois plus
intéressant vous avez les couleurs qui
sont préservés vous avez une belle
colorimétrie ça pour moi ça c'est cool
autre point qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est filtrer la lumière bleue c'est
aujourd'hui un point essentiel les
écrans tire un peu sur le bleu celui là
également vous l'activez et vous mettez
une toute petite opacité parce que si
vous le met à fond
c'est une espèce d'orange et pas très
beau si vous le désactiver ça tire tout
il sole bleu vous venez vous casser un
peu l'effet bleuté ça l'a forcément vous
le réchauffer un peu plus sur le jaune
mais c'est pas mal ça vous protéger tout
de suite de la lumière bleue vous pouvez
aussi régler la luminosité adaptative et
pas mal de paramètres vous pouvez venir
régler dans one day que ce soit pour
l'affichage que ce soit pour autre chose
vous avez aussi le thème font sans ça je
vous laisse regarder
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui marche
très très bien bon jouer à des jeux qui
passera de neuf salles a franchement
bien la pologne
on a la petite encoche ici mais dans
l'absolu ça ne pose absolument aucun
problème pour visionner du contenu
multimédia ça fonctionne aussi vous avez
forcément là tout en poste là il fallait
plus le grand menton mais bon dans
l'absolu pourquoi pas ça va c'est plutôt
pas mal on a vraiment très très beau
savoir ça n'a pas de sens de ce mot
nouveauté l'écran par contre le 2 août
un petit peu criard on a un haut parleur
unique qui est ici qui a ses médiums qui
est assez puissant mais bon point qui
est plutôt intéressante en dessous nous
a laissés sur ce smartphone ici une
petite prise jack alors ça c'est plutôt
bien quand on veut garder comme moi un
bon vieux casque filaire le brancher et
s'écouter directement hop que j'ai envie
de tout faire tomber c'est sensiblement
la même chose avec le casque on a
inspecté un petit peu trop médium là
c'est un point que je pouvais peut
regretter sur ce smartphone à côté de ça
une fois de plus il faut revenir à notre
bonne vieille fille explications 349
pour moi c'est un smartphone qui est
assez rapide on est sur un processeur
milieu de gamme il est assez fluide on à
sigi cadre m derrière ça fonctionne donc
pour des jeux comme asphalt 9
il n'y a pas de souci pour faire tourner
quand même pas mal de jeux du plastoc si
vous aimez jouer mais s'ils voulaient
pas de troupes au plus trop trop trop
trop puissant vous serez franchement
satisfaits ou satisfaits ça c'est
vraiment intéressant c'est pas forcément
un smartphone qui va supporter trop de
multitâche trop d'applications ouvertes
en tâche de fond il ya un moment voilà
il a aussi ses limites
n'oublions pas une faute plus qu'on
essaiera smartphone à 349 euros
maintenant il ya un point qui est très
intéressant là dessus c'est l'autonomie
on a une très grosse batterie très
grosse batterie de 4000 milliampères
heures l'idée c'est que ce smartphone il
va pas vous lâcher pendant deux jours
alors je sais ça dépend toujours de vos
usages à l'époque ce que vous allez en
faire si vous allez beaucoup sollicité
si vous jouez beaucoup une fois de plus
face ça je vous le dis à chaque fois
mais c'est tellement vrai si vous êtes
souvent sur votre smartphone ya un
moment l'autonomie elle va baisser très
rapidement si par contre vous l'utilisez
mais tu as on peut plus raisonner pour
moi de jouer là dessus vous aura
absolument aucun problème
la charge est assez rapide elle n'est
pas encore assez à mon goût
faut bien bien le resituer dernier point
et pas des moindres triple module photo
ici vous avez 25 méga pixels 8
mégapixels et 5 mégapixels avec ça vous
allez pouvoir faire des photos entre
standard vous allez pouvoir faire du
mode portrait et puis voir des photos au
grand temps que le résultat qui est
assez intéressant
je vous emmène avec moi à l'île de ré
j'étais encore hier et regardez c'est
très sympa ça c'est la faute aux
normales là vous
arrivé sur le grand temps alors il ya
une différence de couleur mais ce que
vous ça c'est préserver peut-être un
petit peu trop saturé on va voir l'eau
un petit peu trop verte au niveau du
grand angle mais c'est pas bien grave
pour moi ça pose absolument aucun
problème pour avoir des souvenirs pour
les partager sur les réseaux sociaux
pour montrer à ces chaînes la réalité on
n'est pas sur des photos sursaturé on
est sur une qualité qui franchement
correct mais je trouve que de ce point
de vue là il fait franchement bien la
faire que vous photographiez de la
nourriture que vous photographier des
paysages c'est très très très très très
bien la limite de ce smartphone est en
fait un petit peu la faible luminosité
live à être un peu moins bons faible
luminosité est trop de mouvements là je
suis à l'aquarium de la rochelle il
galère un petit peu sur le mouvement il
est pas hyper hyper hyper bon en faible
luminosité
on perd en détails et même les
hippocampes à concots jours on arrive à
les repérer en plus de ça je trouve que
la prise en main est vachement bien
alors après on est sur un smartphone qui
est pas trop large qui est assez grand
lit sur 16.4 pouces
la prise en main est correct si vous
voulez une à gratter au dessus faut le
faire à demain sinon tout de suite vous
allez galéré maintenant il ya un truc
est importante
je voulais dit tout le temps c'est le
tarif 349 euros à mon avis ce tarif il
va être amené à évoluer et d'ici
quelques mois où vous n'aurez plus à 349
euros
vous n'aurez à un peu moins cher ça ça
casse intéressante c'est que si vous
avez un budget aux alentours de 300
euros
un tout petit peu plus vous pouvez aller
sur ce galaxy à cinq ans parce que ce
galaxy 50 il est intéressant pour quelle
personne il intéressant pour vous il est
fait pour vous si vous voulez un très
bel écran pour visionner du contenu
multimédia si vous aimez bien laisser
les réseaux sociaux si vous voulez
profiter d'un écran qui est lumineux qui
vous accompagnera partout pour pouvoir
regarder des séries pour regarder
youtube pour regarder le monsieur groupe
pourquoi pas sur youtube pour regarder
vos photos pour regarder instagram
ce que vous voulez c'est franchement
bien l'écran est vraiment d'excellente
qualité
ça s'est vraiment bien ce smartphone est
fait pour vous si vous voulez un bel
écran si vous voulez une belle autonomie
si vous voulez des photos en plein jour
qui sont réussis il fonctionnera
parfaitement bien et ça un peu plus de
300 euros
franchement c'est un très bon choix
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire juste là est-ce que cela
5 ans s'il vous plaît est ce que vous
l'avez acheté et est-ce qu'il faut vous
faire de l'oeil alors il ya une très
grosse gabon va tester d'ici quelques
jours le cac40 de chez samsung et au
mexique tout seul faire parce que nous
avons beaucoup échangé que c'est
vachement vachement intéressant j'aime
beaucoup la proposition de valeur la
façon avec laquelle ça me fout les
seuils de renouveler sa gamme à entrée
de gamme milieu de gamme
ils nous font de belles propositions et
je trouve que ça s'est assez
intéressante dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas et n'oubliez pas ce
smartphone vous intéresse
il a effectivement aujourd'hui à 349
euros pouvait l'acheter c'est un très
bon prix a continué à baisser s'il vous
botte
je vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description vous attendez-vous demain
vous embrasse tiens